Test? Okay, nice. Es geht wieder. Ich hatte da so ein kleines Problem gerade.
What is nix?
Okay, ja hier irgendwo sind wir stehen geblieben.
Also ich hatte so ein kleines Problem. Und zwar, ich bin ja gerade am Futtern und wir haben das Video zusammen geguckt.
Und ich wollte den ESP kurz rausziehen aus dem USB und dann bin ich auf den Reset-Knopf gekommen.
Das wäre nicht so schlimm gewesen, wenn nicht Windows-Updates angesprungen wären danach.
Ich musste jetzt legit erst 4 Minuten Windows-Updates machen, bis ich wieder starten durfte.
Geil, oder?
So stellt man sich vor, Kontrolle.
Um über seine Hardware zu haben.
Chat, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Irgendwo hier, oder?
Hier irgendwo sind wir stehen geblieben, glaube ich.
Ich muss hier sind im Dreh.
Ja, Alter.
Kack Windows, man.
Ich war 4 Stunden.
Ich war 4 Stunden 40 knapp on.
Und jetzt sieht es so aus, als wäre ich in der Saison gekommen.
Ich mache bei der Gelegenheit schon mal die VM wieder an.
Weil die ist ja sicherlich auch gecrashed komplett jetzt.
Na klar.
Dädge ist die VM.
Komplett dädge.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Ich futter mein Kram jetzt noch schnell fertig.
Ja, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Let's look at gripgrip, for example.
Which was installed just earlier.
Under bin...
Wir können...
...
Freunde, checken ob vor M geht.
Nice.
Ja, hier haben wir aufgehört.
Okay.
Ja, Chat.
War blöd, dass ich auf reset gekommen bin, aber...
Willste machen.
Anschwabas mal einfach den Uf.
Grip an alle, die es nicht gecheckt haben, 2 Minuten zu warten, der 5 zu drücken.
Letztes Mal, kurzer, kurzer Check.
Von den angeblich 85 Leuten, die den Stream aufhaben, wer ist denn alles am starren?
Nur mal so, dass ich überhaupt weiß, ob das Twitch schon kapiert hat, dass ich wieder
da bin, richtig?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Ist gut.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Twitch.
Twitch hat's gecheckt.
Alles gut.
Passt.
Ist gut.
Alles klar.
Was letzte Ping?
Okay.
Gucken wir das Video jetzt mal schnell fertig.
Ich hab noch ein halbes Toastbrot.
Das ist ein cooles Feature, das gefällt mir, wenn du einfach mal was ausprobieren willst.
Dann sagst du nix Shell minus P installierst das, dann kriegst du ein Shell mit den.
Das ist cool.
Guter Delay.
Du musst mal deinen Browser refreshen.
Ich hab keinen Delay.
So gut wie keinen.
Ich seh's hier auf meinem zweiten Bildschirm.
Muss Browser refreshen.
Side-Refreshen, dann geht's.
Das ist ein cooles Feature.
Das gefällt mir.
Auf der anderen Seite, Docker Run, irgendeine Distribution, wo das drinnen ist, install,
geht genauso.
Aber hier hast du halt ein riesengroßes Repo mit allem möglichen Zeug drin.
Das gefällt mir.
Mixed Temporary Shell, that I can still run on my local files, unlike an un...
Warte, Frage, Chat.
Wie hat es NixOS eigentlich gelöst?
Mit Binaries, die abhängig sind von deiner lokalen GLIB-C?
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Die bringen wahrscheinlich alle dann jeweils ihre eigene Version mit.
Rate ich jetzt einfach mal.
Unmounted Docker Container.
And I can see it comes from a local bin.
Leaving the shell, however, I can see that Kause is gone.
It's not really gone, of course.
It was never there in the first place.
Let's push Nix even further and try to use it as a declarative package management system.
By that I mean providing it with a list of packages for a reproducible environment with
the tooling I...
Was schreibt der da?
By that I mean providing it...
Ah!
FZF, äh, Fuzzy Search.
Das Terminal sieht cool aus.
Muss ich ihm lassen.
Mir ist das aber viel zu fancy.
Das Terminal sieht cool aus.
Und so viel zu viel, soll ich sagen, bewegte Dinger, ja, in dem Terminal.
Für mich ist es nix, aber Terminal ist ja an sich eine sehr individuelle Sache.
Ich mag mein Terminal-Style.
Ich mag auch die meisten Standard-Tools.
Ich benutze auch nach wie vor LS und nicht EXA oder sonst was.
Oder setze x-beliebiges Tool written in Rust ein.
Für Schmacksache.
Und ich bin auch ein Fan von zweizeiligen Prompts.
Wegen genau dem, was man eben im Video gesehen hat vor 10 Minuten.
Ja.
fertig essen. Was haben wir noch spannendes hier? Moller nix. Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich gucke mir das
nachher mal fertig an, aber irgendwie habe ich immer noch nicht so richtig, weiß nicht so,
noch nicht den richtig großen Vorteil erkannt, ehrlich gesagt. Okay, einen Vorteil sehe ich,
wenn ich tatsächlich was installieren möchte, was es halt nicht gibt, weder im Auer noch als
Flatback noch als irgendwas anderes, dann macht das durchaus Sinn, was über nix zu installieren.
Gibt es das auch für Windows, Leute? Gibt es das für WSL? Ja, wahrscheinlich. Also auch
ein Ubuntu. Dafür ist es ganz cool, aber die ganzen anderen Features, ja, ich weiß es nicht.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Nachdem ich ja so ungeschickt war und meine Reset-Button gepusht habe,
ist natürlich auch, hat sich auch natürlich alles geschlossen, was offen war. Wo waren wir denn
stehen geblieben? Ah ja, wir haben den, wir haben konfiguriert, dass der sich per WLAN verbindet,
richtig? Das stimmt schon, das, ja, aber ich frage mich, wie gut man mit einem Immutable-Home-Director
beispielsweise arbeiten kann. Das sehe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich bin, ich bin da noch
unschlüssig, vielleicht müsste ich das einfach mal ausprobieren. Vielleicht müsste ich es einfach
mal ausprobieren und mir irgendwie mal so ein paar Monate geben, ob ich dann den großen, ob ich dann
auch zum großen Nix OS Checker werde und ich dann nicht mehr sage, dass ich Arch by the way verwende,
sondern dass ich Arch plus Nix by the way verwende, sondern, eigentlich müssen wir sagen, ich verwende,
Knu plus Linux
Nein
Arch Knu plus
Linux mit
Nix Packages
Korrekt?
Oh, ein bisschen großer Hacker,
mein Name, Staat. So,
alles klar. Chatgear, wo sind
wir stehen geblieben?
Wir haben geschaut, dass
es ein
Ich bin noch da, ja.
Ich habe aus Versehen den Reset-Knopf gedrückt.
Und dann musste ich
Windows-Updates machen.
Omega-Lull. Ja, unpraktisch.
Hypercringe.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Oh, Leute, ich habe vergessen, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Ach ja, ich weiß wieder.
Also, wo ist der ESP? Ich muss den ESP erstmal
wieder anschließen. Und diesmal
ohne den Reset-Knopf
zu drücken, man.
So.
Stream. Zack.
Äh, CD.
Repos.
Wie ist das Ding? Display Champ.
Display Champ. Monitor.
Export.
Monitor.
Okay. Also, er versucht sich immer noch
per WLAN zu verbinden und das Ganze funktioniert nicht.
So, da sind wir stehen geblieben.
So.
Also.
Hier soll er nächstes Point
aufmachen, wenn er keine WLAN-Settings
am Start hat. Das
lassen wir heute mal bleiben. Das
muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Ja.
Ob man mal Listen hat, DPS.
Ne, passt schon. Gut. Dann testen
wir das doch jetzt mal mit
echten WiFi-Credentials.
Ich traue mich, die einfach mal in Flash zu
schreiben. Das müssen wir
einmal machen.
Und dann kann ich
rebooten. Normalerweise,
macht man das dann über, übers Handy. Initiale
Einrichtung. Also, machen wir jetzt hier
WiFi 1. Passwort gleich
WiFi
Pass. Ne, oh, fuck.
Ich habe vergessen, wie ich es genannt habe.
WLAN. WLAN habe ich es bestimmt genannt. WLAN-Passwort.
WLAN-Passwort
und WLAN
SSID.
So, und wenn das jetzt stimmt,
Save. Ne, Config.
Write to Flash.
Write to Flash. Wenn das
jetzt von nichts liegt, ja, glücklicherweise
Autocompleted das nicht genug, dass man es hier sieht.
Ich habe auch, ich habe auch keinerlei...
Ne, ich habe keine, ich habe keine, irgendwie, Logging-Outputs. Ne, ne, nicht Monitoren.
Logging-Outputs davon.
Ja, ich schreibe das jetzt in Flash.
Und
dann lösche ich das wieder und dann sollte
der sich wieder ins WLAN verbinden.
Und hoffentlich
können wir dann uns die Daten ins Webinterface
schicken lassen, aber ohne mein Passwort
zu liegen. Wow.
What the f... Achso, ja, das ist gut so.
Wir turnen ja auch, ja.
Okay, gut. Doch die SSID
habt ihr gesehen. Was interessiert mich die SSID?
So eine 0815-Random-SSID, die es 500
Mal in Deutschland gibt. Äh, das
Passwort ist das, was ich nicht leaken will.
Die SSID
ist nicht das Geheim. So.
Prage.
Aha. Es funzt.
Schauen wir mal, was wir für ein Websocket kriegen.
Jawohl, er hat sich wieder verbunden.
Excellent. Und die anderen
WiFi-Sachen sind noch gesetzt.
Und auch keine
komischen Passwort-Dinger,
die er
verrät. Ja. Also, sehr nice.
Dann können wir doch mal
ein super hässliches Webinterface
bauen zum Setzen von
WiFi-Credentials.
Aber
das wird jetzt wirklich abartig
hässliches Webinterface. Kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen.
Passwort. Ja, ne.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 Leute. Leaked.
Okay. Das funzt
schon mal. Wir fügen
mal, weil es geht, Tailwind
hinzu, weil ich der absolute
Hyper-Kack-NOOB
Webentwickler bin.
Äh.
Moved.
Ah. Okay. Warum auch immer.
Äh. Tailwind.
Tailwind.
Gibt es da? Guck mal, die haben eine neue Seite.
Tailwind CSS.
NPX.
Svelte-Ad.
Typography. Ne, die machen wir an, sonst sieht's
kacke aus.
Truge.
Welchen Sensor steuerst du an?
Du meinst für die Temperaturausgabe?
Den internen CPU-Temperatursensor.
Einfach nur, dass ich ein paar
Werte hab, die da
auftauchen.
Precondition failed. Natürlich
wish ich to continue.
Okay. So, haben wir Tailwind.
Jetzt am Start.
Profile-Web. Okay.
Also, wir sollten Tailwind am Start haben.
Jetzt können wir. Äh.
Chat.
Warum ist das so auf einmal oben?
Ich glaube, das ist das,
dieses Tailwind-Ding hat komische Dinger getrieben
gerade. What the fuck?
Äh.
Okay. Ja, wir sollten das mal umformatieren lassen.
Ja, jetzt ist es
wieder richtig formatiert. Okay.
Also, wir sollten Tailwind am Start haben.
Das heißt,
wir machen mal jetzt eine superhässliche
HTML, superhässliche Form,
ja?
Du kannst, wobei das super
trickreich ist. Hier, ESP32
Read Temperature.
Das ist nicht offiziell.
Also, es gibt zwar eine
Funktion dafür,
aber
du siehst ja auch schon,
manche Boards haben's,
manche Boards haben es nicht.
In Fahrenheit.
Okay. Ja, wie jetzt?
Hier ist es in Celsius.
Manche Boards haben es manchmal nicht.
Das ist so eine semi-offizielle Sache,
dass die einen CPU-Temperatursensor
drinnen haben.
So, also Tailwind-Skiller hier am Start
jetzt. Frontend-Stells.
Frontend-Stells.
Also, das da unten können wir mal da lassen.
Okay, pass mal auf.
Massive.
Äh. Navbar.
Boah, ey.
Ich geb mir jetzt keine Mühe.
Ich mach jetzt einfach, ich mach jetzt einfach
ein Formular mit einem Button,
dass wir testen können,
ob ich übers
Web-Interface die WiFi-Sachen
setzen kann. Okay?
Wir wollen nicht übertreiben.
Also, dann schmeißen wir diesen Campbell hier mal weg.
Brauchen wir ja nicht. So, auskommentiert.
Also, wir brauchen eine Form.
Form-Action brauchen wir alles nicht.
Submit.
OnSubmit. Ja, das ist okay.
Submit Function.
Function.
Submit.
Keine Ahnung. Event.
Man kann glaube ich einfach sowas hier so.
Es gibt bestimmt esoterische Wege.
Ja, du kannst bestimmt mit
irgendeinem Mikrofon über die Schwingungen
der
Kondensatoren
irgendwie. Ja, gibt's bestimmt jede Menge
Wege für.
So, Input.
Okay, wir haben ein Input-Feld.
Sieht hässlich oldschool aus, aber es ist ein Input-Feld.
Okay? Oh, gut.
Kann man hier Forms auch installieren?
Kann das irgendwie?
Kann das typography?
Also,
wir haben hier eine Form.
Die, ja, keine Ahnung.
Placeholder.
Wifi 1
SSID.
Wifi 2
Ne, ne, ne. So kann man
das nicht lassen.
Pass mal auf.
CSS-Hackerman am Start jetzt.
Flex.
Column.
Warum geht das nicht?
Sollte das jetzt nicht eigentlich untereinander stehen?
Warum steht das
nicht untereinander?
Warum kann ein CSS nicht einfach mal
irgendwas auf die Art und Weise funktionieren,
wie man sich das denkt?
Was könnte das denn sein?
Ah, ich hab eine Idee.
Vielleicht muss ich sowas sagen wie
Breite von der Seite?
Ne.
Alter.
Ich bin einfach zu dumm für CSS.
Musst du nicht
die Klassen importieren in einer speziellen Datei?
Richtig.
Und es ist die Frage,
ob es das gemacht hat.
Da hast du recht.
Hier ab CSS.
Ja.
Boah, mein Auge!
Dark Mode ist
weg.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Muss ich noch npm install machen?
Hab ich npm install vergessen?
Vielleicht?
Ne.
Wir testen mal, ob es funktioniert.
Und zwar sagen wir einfach hier
background-red
Okay, das funzt nicht.
Irgendwie ist Tailwind nicht aktiv.
Warum?
CSS wird importiert.
Was hab ich falsch gemacht?
Hab ich da irgendwas?
War genau das, was ich ausgeführt hab, oder?
Äh.
Warum ist der Tailwind nicht
am Start hier?
Was ist da jetzt verkehrt?
Irgendeine
chlorreiche
Idee?
App CSS?
Haben wir App CSS drin?
Ich weiß es nicht. Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Er sagt ja auch hier
unknown rules Tailwind.
Was hat sonst so irgendwas drinne
stehen hier?
Hat er einen Error geworfen beim installieren?
Operation
cancel danach.
Hat alles funktioniert angeblich.
Und ich hab auch
explizit gesagt, nochmal npm install.
Was ihn auch nicht weiter
interessiert.
Das ist halt so das geile bei Frontend Sachen.
Es funktioniert immer irgend etwas nicht.
Kann ich Link schicken? Ja.
Ich weiß was.
Ich starte einfach mal Vite neu.
Bestimmt ist es nach Vite.
Bestimmt ist es da.
Easy, da ist es. Hat funktioniert.
Wobei, so
halb.
Ne doch, es hat funktioniert.
Ich glaub wir müssen
noch die Höhe angeben.
Ah ja, okay.
Jetzt ist der Hintergrund.
Was ist ein schöner Hintergrund?
BG
Grey
Neutral
Neutral 900
Ist ja ein schöner Darkmode Hintergrund.
Ich hab kein Svelte Kit, ich hab eine reine
Svelte Anwendung.
Meine Inputs sehen halt massiv hässlich aus.
Willste machen.
Dann können wir jetzt vielleicht hier noch
sagen
dass wir irgendwie so einen Gap machen
oder sowas.
Äh, äh.
Äh, besser, besser.
Kleiner Gap.
Ich mach mal 800. Wo muss ich gerade? Ah doch.
900, 900 ist ein guter Hintergrund.
Ultra Darkmode.
Massive Darkmode.
Was meinen die? 800 oder 900?
Ne, 900 ist schon okay für Darkmode.
Jetzt muss ich die Inputs irgendwie.
Ganz ehrlich, ich komm auch mit ungestylten
Inputs heute zurechte.
Minimalste Inputs.
Minimalste Inputstyles.
Sowas wie
Text, LG.
Ah, dass man auch was
erkennt.
Dann brauchen wir zumindest ein bisschen
Padding.
Ja, okay. Reicht.
Hübsch genuger Input.
Wifi
Passwort.
Na, copy-paste wäre das Ganze jetzt nochmal.
Wifi 2
Passwort.
Was ist ein schöner...
Was ist ein schöner Hintergrund
für so einen...
Scheiß drauf, ich mach das mal kurz weg.
Was ist ein schöner Hintergrund? Komm, wir machen.
Wir sind mal nicht so.
Zack. New File.
Input.
Passwort als Teil.
Passwort. Jaja, auf jeden Fall müssen wir das machen.
Jetzt zum Testen
ist erstmal egal, weil ich ja nix
leake an der Stelle.
Oh.
Kann man das jetzt inputten?
Irgendwie importen oder so?
Okay, nice. Jetzt heißt das natürlich überall
Wifi SSID 1.
Okay, das ist schon mal doof.
Script.
Oh, wie war das?
Svelte 5.
Svelte 5 Component Party.
Müssen wir uns angucken.
Difference.
Svelte 4 zu Svelte 5.
Vergleich. Hier.
Props.
Äh.
Ah ja. So ging das.
Name.
Eigentlich, ja.
Keine Ahnung. Name.
Okay, komm.
Name ist leer.
Ja.
Name.
3.
1 SSID.
Okay. So.
Dann brauchen wir noch nen Gap.
Gap von 2. Kann man durchgucken.
Und das allerwichtigste,
was jeder, was jedes gute
Inputfeld braucht. Rounded.
Ohne. Leute, sieht
die Seite nicht einfach schon tausendmal
professioneller aus? Nur mit
Rounded Corners. Massive.
Richtige Augenweide, die Seite.
Ah.
BG.
Neutral.
Ach. 800.
Okay.
Das sieht legit gar nicht mal so kacke aus von der Farbwahl
jetzt. Der Senior von den Deaf
ist am Start, ja.
Boxshadow sieht man da eh net.
Was ich mich jetzt frage
ist, wie macht man
den Cursor denn jetzt
schöner? Gibt es da irgendwie
Cursor? Ne.
Ah. Das ist bestimmt.
Textcolor, oder?
Also wenn ich den Text
Red mache, dann ist der Cursor auch Red.
Korrekt.
Six Head Time.
Textcolor. Keine Ahnung.
Neutral. 100.
Jetzt. Ah. Sieht auch ganz brauchbar aus.
Okay. Für heute
reicht das. Ist genug.
Okay. Da. Das ist
Wifi SSID 1.
Wifi SSID 2.
Äh.
Wifi.
1 Passwort.
Oh. Das reicht jetzt.
Okay. Passt.
Ja. Hast du recht.
Das ist Blödsinn, wie ich das gemacht habe. Das muss schon so sein.
So. Das reicht jetzt
für heute. So. Dann machen wir den Button.
Ein
äh. Ja.
Button. Hier. Button.
Button.
Hack. Oh ja. Hier.
Alles klar. Erkennt man. Ah ne. Da reloadet
er ja, wenn ich da drauf klicke. Ist keine gute Idee.
Ja. Also wir machen einen Button
für.
Für den Button.
Ja. Save.
Save und ein Button für.
Für. Für.
Für Factory Reset.
Cancel gibt es nicht.
Es wird nur Factory Reset oder Saved. Alles andere
gibt es hier nicht.
Und der Button.
Der kriegt.
Ähm.
Keine Ahnung.
BG Green.
Das ist immerhin der Save Button.
Boah. Sieht das hässlich aus.
Ah.
Äh. Gefällt mir nicht.
Emerald vielleicht. Emerald.
Ja. Aber ganz
wichtig Leute. Round it.
Text. LG.
Jawoll.
Boah. Was ein geiler Button.
Oder? Massive Button.
Und Text.
Neutral.
Was habe ich hier? Neutral 100.
Okay. Das sieht kacke aus.
Und Bold.
Schon besser.
Aber vielleicht ein bisschen dunkler.
Vollwertig. Ey.
Das geht klar oder?
Leute. Geht voll klar.
Ja. Sieh mal.
Das geht voll klar. So. Save Button.
Mehr brauchen wir nicht. Alles. Alles.
Und dann kommt ein Reset Button gibt es auch noch.
Reset. Reset Button.
Reset. Der ist aber nicht rot.
Der ist äh.
Rosé.
600. 700.
Ganz toll.
Boah. Ja. Frontend.
Senior Frontend Dev am Werk. Leute.
Was ich da baue. Ein Web Interface.
Was auf meinem ESP32 läuft.
Der hier unten sich einen ab.
Ähm. Zappelt. Das ist dieses Board.
Hier. Dieses Board.
Läuft das drauf.
Webserver über HTTPS. Der dann diese
Web Anwendung ausliefert.
Und darüber kann ich jetzt neue
WiFi Credentials setzen.
Ich trink die ganze Zeit.
Heute habe ich Wasserflasche hier stehen.
Okay. Jetzt.
Trick 17 Leute.
Fifehead Time.
Wir machen jetzt hier noch hier. Placeholder
ist leer. Standardmäßig.
Aber Placeholder
kann man setzen.
Und zwar Placeholder.
Guck mal hier. Placeholder
ist quasi
Config
Ähm.
Ich bin zu noob. Wie habe ich
das genannt?
Config
3 1 Passwort Set.
Achso. Moment. Ich kack nur.
Placeholder soll.
Ähm. Okay. Wenn Placeholder
Default ist der Place. Ey. Das
Funst. Sehr gut. Sehr gut.
Ähm. Aber trotzdem nicht
so schlau.
Ähm. Ich brauche ein Label oder sowas. Gell.
Was ich hier baue. Ein
Web Interface für mein ESP32.
Dass ich meine WiFi Credentials ändern kann.
Ich brauche so eine Art Label.
Glaube ich.
Label. Vor. Oh. Wie
funs das. Form.
Formularelemente. Ich habe keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert.
Vor. Ja. Das läuft
auf dem ESP32.
Ähm. Ja.
Weiß ich nicht. Kack.
Ip.
Label. Input.
Ich kenne mich damit nicht aus.
Wie funktioniert. Das Label Element.
For Cheese.
Input. Name. Name Cheese.
Okay. Oder muss es auch ID Cheese
sein. Dass es funktioniert.
Value brauche ich auch noch. Ja.
Okay. Name gleich Name.
Das ist schon mal easy.
Funs das jetzt. Wenn ich da drauf klicke.
Ne. Natürlich nicht. Muss ich dem Ding ernsthaft
eine ID geben. Wirklich.
Kack.
HD. Ja. Dann funktioniert
das mit dem Fokussieren.
Das ist ja Old School
Shit hoch 10. Mann.
Okay. Class gleich.
Äh. Habe ich Text.
Neutral.
Drei mal so lang wie das C++ Zeug. Ich sag's euch.
Ähm.
Pwned. Bold.
Und dann noch
ein Doppelpunkt dahinter. Okay.
Name.
Okay. Das ist ganz
brauchbar. Placeholder ist
3. Das geht doch ganz gut
klar für ein Formular.
So. Wifi set.
Passwort 2.
Wifi set.
Da soll natürlich nicht
true drinne stehen.
Sondern. Oh. Wir brauchen noch einen Spinner
gleich. Da soll natürlich nicht
true drinne stehen. Sondern wenn das gesetzt
ist. Dann soll da
drinne stehen. Sternchen. Sternchen.
Sternchen. Sternchen. Sternchen.
Und ansonsten nix.
Das sieht gar nicht so schlecht
aus Leute. Das sieht
gar nicht mal so kacke aus.
So.
Aber du hast Recht. Ein Value brauche ich natürlich.
Das stimmt.
Zumindest brauche ich ein
Initialen Value.
Mehr will ich gar nicht.
Glaube ich.
Zumindest.
Sind die Thinkpads echt zu gut?
Ehrlich gesagt. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hatte seit Jahren kein Thinkpad mehr.
Das letzte Thinkpad was ich hatte.
Das hat noch Metallscharniere gehabt.
Und kam tatsächlich noch von IBM.
Also. Ich weiß es nicht.
Okay. Dann brauchen wir noch Value.
Wobei ich das hier ehrlich gesagt
eigentlich nur der initiale
Value sein soll.
Einmalig quasi so gesetzt.
Einmalig gesetzt.
Ne.
Ah.
Da schießen wir uns glaube ich selbst ins Bein.
Durch das permanente geupdate hier unten gerade.
Ja das ist ja doof.
Wenn ich da permanent update dann.
Ah. Wenn ich das öffne.
Dann muss ich einmal einen Snapshot davon machen irgendwie.
Mal schauen.
So. Value können wir jetzt übergeben.
Und zwar Value hier.
Value.
Value ist gleich.
Wifi 1 Passwort ist nicht gesetzt.
Wifi 1.
SSID.
Nice.
Okay. Okay. Gut.
Das updatet sich. Ach. Das updatet sich nicht.
Okay.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, dass sich die Config hier
regelmäßig updatet.
Da habe ich irgendwas ins Welt wahrscheinlich noch nicht gecheckt.
Ganz.
Wobei ich das auch gut finde.
Weil sonst würde das permanent überschrieben werden.
Das wäre auch ganz schön blöd.
So. Und jetzt.
Wir brauchen noch das allerwichtigste Leute.
Wir brauchen einen Spinner.
Bis die Seite geladen ist. Guckt mal.
Die Seite braucht ein bisschen bis es lädt.
Und dann.
Ich will nicht das es lädt.
Weil wenn es lädt.
Dann stürzt es ab.
Aber wenn es lädt und die Daten noch nicht da sind.
Sieht kacke aus. Oder?
Wir brauchen noch einen Spinner.
Und zwar.
Wie machen wir denn jetzt einen gescheiten Spinner?
Iconify.
Wir tricksen. Wir tricksen mit dem Spinner.
Ich habe keinen Bock einen eigenen Spinner zu machen hier.
Icons.
Spinner.
Ähm.
Haben die nicht eigentlich Animationen?
Haben die nicht eigentlich auch auf der Seite CSS Animationsbilder drauf?
Äh.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Spinnern die nicht? Woran liegt das?
Darkreader vielleicht?
Auf SVG umstellen.
Ne ist schon.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher.
Die hatten mal.
Icons mit Animationen.
Ah hier. Haben sie welche mit Animationen.
Ok geil.
Wenn man nach Spinner sucht.
Findet man nur welche ohne.
Aber Loading findet man welche mit Animationen.
Nice. So ist das.
Weil wir können jetzt einfach dieses Ding hier nehmen.
Und das SVG kopieren.
Und schon.
Ratzfatz.
Haben wir nen Spinner.
Auf unserer Webseite.
Der aber ziemlich scheiße aussieht noch.
Aber wir haben nen Spinner.
So.
Und den. Wir machen das jetzt so.
Äh.
Let loading gleich true.
Und sobald.
Ich den ersten.
Die ersten Werte hier krieg.
Dann sagen wir loading gleich false.
Und wir zeigen den Spinner.
Äh.
Wie macht man das jetzt gescheit.
Machen wir ein if.
Machen wir ein if drum.
If.
Wie ging nochmal ein if ins Welt.
Und wie geht nen else.
Else.
Genau also.
If loading.
Dann kommt der Spinner.
Ansonsten nicht.
So.
Wir müssen den Spinner aber noch schön formatieren.
Sonst sieht das kacke aus.
Und das andere kommt rein.
Wenn der Spinner nicht angezeigt wird.
Oh. Moment.
Nicht das ganze Main.
Main muss da drum rum.
Hab ich euch schon mal gesagt.
Das mir Frontend Sachen immer extrem auf den Keks gehen.
So.
Okay.
Und wie stylen wir den Spinner jetzt gescheit.
Sag mal.
Seh ich das richtig.
Hat dieser Autoformatierer für HTML.
Wirklich ne schweifende SVG Klammer.
Auf ne eigene Zeile gesetzt.
Hä.
Ey keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung man.
Frontend stells.
Okay. Class.
Text gleich neutral 100.
Okay man erkennt den Spinner.
Und.
Ja dann sagen wir jetzt noch hier.
Weiß ich.
Text.
XXL.
Bam.
Massive geiler Spinner am Start.
Ist nicht der.
Nicestes Spinner den ihr je gesehen habt.
Ich find schon oder.
Der spielt ganz vorne mit.
So.
Und wie.
Wie.
Wie kriegt man den jetzt in die Mitte.
Text.
Ne Align oder so.
Align.
Center. Irgendwas mit Center.
Text Center.
Da bin ich wieder zu.
Dumm für.
Wie man das jetzt in der Mitte alignt.
Text Center.
Nein.
Eindeutig zu.
Wie krieg ich denn das jetzt in die Mitte.
Okay.
Massive nicer High IQ Chat.
Ah.
Äh.
Wo kommen denn diese komischen.
Okay.
Screen wollen wir schon mal net.
Und das auch net.
Aber W full können wir machen.
Das ist schon okay.
Okay.
Nice.
Massive Spinner.
Okay.
Und wenn jetzt alles richtig funktioniert.
Dann sollten wir.
Reloaden Spinner.
Und Zack.
Wenn die Daten geladen sind.
Kommt das Formular.
Senior Frontend Entwickler.
In the making.
Nice.
Okay jetzt haben wir so ein schönes Formular.
Wir machen übrigens keine.
Formular Validierung oder so.
Komische.
Komische Dinger.
Also jetzt noch nicht.
Das schaff ich heut geistig.
Nehmen wir Frontend Formular Validierung.
Ne Backend ist schon da.
Das ist ja das geilste.
Ne aber noch nicht komplett.
Noch nicht komplett.
Aber Backend ist zum größten halt schon da.
Ich mach da noch ein bisschen Abstand dazwischen.
Oder?
Das ist schicker.
Das ist schicker so.
Okay.
Wie.
Kriege ich jetzt.
Daraus.
Okay Submit.
Wie kriege ich in dem Submit Event.
Okay als erstes.
Muss ich in dem Submit Event schon mal sagen.
Das ich eigentlich das gar nicht verwenden will.
Also.
Revent.
Event.
Default.
So das muss ich machen.
Der checkt wieder etwas.
Okay ich gebe zu es ist kein TypeScript.
Aber.
Chatgear.
Man kann das doch irgendwie annotaten.
Auch mit JavaScript.
JSDoc.
Ne.
JSDoc Event.
Wie geht denn das.
Ja.
Ich check schon wieder nicht.
Scheiß drauf.
Content Crap.
Also.
Submit.
Wie kriege ich da jetzt.
Die Formularsachen ausgelesen.
Gibt es da irgendwas.
Drinnen.
Machen wir mal E.
Wir loggen das Event einfach mal.
Save.
Okay ganz viel Zeug.
Gibt es da sowas wie.
Keine Ahnung.
Könnten das heißen.
Get Form Data from Submit Event.
Even contain the Form Data.
Target. Aha.
Excellent.
Das ist das was ich haben will.
Und sogar mit E.
Save.
Array.
Da ist es guck hier.
Wifi SSID.
Wifi Passwort.
Sehr gut.
Nice.
Okay.
Jetzt haben wir Form Data am Start.
Und jetzt muss ich Form Data irgendwie.
Validaten.
Geht das so.
Kann ich jetzt sagen.
Entries.
Next.
WTF.
Wie soll man das benutzen jetzt.
So.
Ne undefined.
Was auch sonst.
Data was gibt es da sonst noch.
Gibt es da sowas wie get.
Ah ja.
Hier get.
Get wollen wir haben.
Wifi SSID.
Ah.
Ja ja.
Excellent.
Okay dann machen wir mal hier so einen.
Let.
Oder const.
Payload gleich.
Leeres Objekt.
Okay.
Ne Moment.
Moment.
Also ich will den Websocket Request machen.
Wo die Sachen drinstehen.
Ähm.
Also.
Das heißt.
Ja eigentlich kann ich doch mehr oder weniger die Form Data.
Da zurück.
Zurück liefern oder.
Kann man Form Data.
Jason Stringifyen.
Gescheit.
Jason Stringify Form Data.
Geht das.
Ne.
Das geht natürlich nicht.
Das wäre jetzt ja auch viel zu einfach gewesen.
Wenn das funktioniert.
Kann ich sagen hier.
Get all.
Was kommt dann.
Äh.
What.
Okay das funktioniert nicht.
Also muss man.
Also muss man das quasi so machen.
Ne.
Geht nicht.
Das da.
Ja.
Okay.
Nice.
Irgendwann müssen wir noch.
Das.
Bisschen Validaten.
Was da als Input reinkommt.
Weil sonst kann sich einfach einer sein Passwort löschen.
Das ist dann.
Dumm.
Einer muss das an.
Das ist dann.
Dann.
Also.
Okay.
Das ist dann.
So.
Okay.
Ich.
irgendwie checken können, was das für eine Message ist, die da
reinkommt. Also machen wir irgendwie sowas wie
Type, wenn ich mal Type oder
Message Type
ist
Wifi
und ja
Content
ist
dann mein Payload.
Aha.
Schauen wir mal, ob da jetzt was ankommt.
Ja!
Okay, Backend-Technik
kommt die Sache schon mal an.
Wifi-Message
Wifi-Content hier, bla bla bla
steht halt nix da.
Da wird nix
geleakt. Und wenn ich da was
reinschreib,
Wifi-Passwort 2, Save,
dann steht das drinnen.
Okay. Mega nice.
Das heißt, wir gehen jetzt hier beim Web-Server hin
an der Stelle, wo
der
die Web-Socket-Sachen
handelt.
Ja.
Und
da checken wir jetzt,
was der Client sendet.
Und wenn der Client
ungültiges JSON
sendet, machen wir nix. Und wenn da
Wifi drinnen steht, dann machen wir was.
Dann machen wir nochmal hier eine extra Methode,
sowas wie
Handle
Web-Socket
JSON oder sowas.
So, das
kriegt einen String.
Das ist nämlich, oder sagen wir hier, das ist die Message im Endeffekt.
So, Message.
Hier haben wir das Ganze gelesen.
Dann rufen wir das auf.
Also, Handle.
Handle Web-Socket-JSON.
Okay, jetzt muss ich mal kurz
nachdenken.
Ist das hier Zero-Terminated?
Ich glaube, ja.
Aber ich habe ja auch die Länge.
Also kann ich im Endeffekt doch sowas sagen.
Hier, String.
String, Duster, plus
brauche ich die Länge?
Plus Web-Socket
Length.
Ja, okay, das Funz.
Das Funz, nice.
Oh Mann, das ist verwirrend.
Vor allem nach,
Leute, wir sind schon über 5 Stunden.
Wir sind 5 Stunden 30 oder so on.
Dafür kann ich mich noch erstaunlich gut konzentrieren gerade.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Ja, schade, dass der Stream
zwischendrin abgekackt ist.
Machste nix.
So, und jetzt muss ich im Prinzip
das Ganze mal checken.
Jason, ne, jetzt muss ich das
parsen erst mal.
Jason, deserialize.
Geht nicht.
Deserialize Jason?
Ja, wie auch sonst.
So, Message, da rein.
Geht das?
Richtig rum? Ne.
Ah, falsch rum.
Da, so rum.
Okay.
So, und jetzt kann ich gucken.
If.
Von dem Jason, was gesendet wird,
ist das
Message Type
gleich
ähm
Wifi.
Was passiert denn eigentlich bei dem Vergleich hier?
Ah, der kann das.
Okay, wenn der Message Type gleich Wifi ist,
dann will ich was machen.
Und zwar, dann will ich, was will ich denn da machen?
Dann will ich App Config
die App Config laden
und dann die Sachen auf die Disk speichern.
Okay.
Also, Config.
Wir machen jetzt nur SSID 2.
Den Rest fasse ich gar nicht an.
Doc.
Wifi SSID 2.
Hoffentlich habe ich das immer gleich genannt.
Und Wifi 2 Passwort.
Äh, was aus irgendwelchen Gründen
jetzt nicht funktioniert.
Warum? Weil es ein String ist
und das ist unbekannt.
Ähm, muss ich das
muss ich das casten?
Was, was ist denn nur mit casten los?
Ich muss das, ich muss das bestimmt.
Ah, du hast recht.
Du hast recht.
Content habe ich es genannt, ja.
Vielleicht, weißt du was?
Wir nennen das auch Payload.
Weil, ne?
Schon verwirrend. Payload.
Ja, richtig.
Aber der checkt trotzdem nicht, dass das
muss das bestimmt
casten als String.
Ich hoffe du das findest.
Und jetzt
config
save, ne write.
Write to flash, bam.
Jetzt bin ich
ja mal gespannt, ob das, ach ne
und ähm
Wifi 1 first
ist ein Bool.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal
gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Was ich da zusammengestrickt habe.
Also von der Idee her, was jetzt
passieren sollte.
Ich klicke diesen Mist hier an den
ESP. Der ESP
überschreibt hoffentlich nicht
mein Wifi 1, weil das
brauche ich zum testen. Der ESP
sollte umschalten auf
Wifi 2
und
das geht nicht. Und dann
zurückfallen auf mein schon
bekanntes Wifi.
Okay, okay.
Also hier dran ändere ich nix.
So, wir wollen nicht, wir wollen
in Pepo Schall 2 uns connecten jetzt.
Und
massive geiles Passwort.
Habt ihr
auch nie gesehen. So.
Okay.
Save.
Hat nicht funktioniert.
Weil ist das denn da neu gestartet?
Ah.
F klein geschrieben.
Aber eigentlich ganz gut, dass
der da nicht abkackt bei, sondern es einfach nix
macht. Also scheint schon mal
nicht ganz so beschissen programmiert zu sein.
PauseChamp.
Hat der Stream gerade geleckt?
Ey, oder?
Okay, nochmal ausprobieren alles hier.
Wir wollen in Pepo Schall 2
Autocomplete muss ich auch ausschalten.
Ey, guck mal wie hässlich das ist.
Oh.
Ey, das hat, das hat mein Formkap...
Das hat...
Pepo Schall 2.
Okay, whatever, whatever.
Save. Bäm.
Oh, das sieht gut aus, Leute.
Es hängt. Es hängt.
Und jetzt verbindet er sich
mit dem anderen. Das hat funktioniert.
Hat er sich versucht zu Pepo Schall 2
zu verbinden? Es geht.
Ich kann WiFi Sachen setzen
über das Webinterface.
Oh.
Was nackt, Alter.
What the fuck.
Oh.
Hat nur knapp 6 Stunden gedauert.
MonkaS.
Aber der WiFi Fallback
funktioniert auch.
Guck, er hat zuerst
versucht, das neue WLAN zu
connecten. Hat nicht funktioniert
und er ist Fallback zum alten WLAN.
So muss
das sein. Hog.
Massive.
Hog.
Wir machen jetzt hier vielleicht noch eine
Sache, ganz auf die Schnelle, weil ich auch
nicht finde, dass das schön ist, wenn man das so
sieht.
Und zwar haben wir
jetzt hier noch
Type. Standardmäßig
ist der Type Text, aber
man kann den auch
setzen. Und zwar können wir sagen,
dass der
Type hier
soll
gleich Passwort sein.
Ja, jetzt sieht man auch nichts mehr.
Excellent. Sehr gut.
Oh, was ein
Eck, Mann.
Alter.
Aber ihr müsst mal zugeben,
ich hab schon hässlichere Webinterfaces
produziert, oder?
Es sieht gar nicht mal so scheiße aus.
Aber natürlich hauptsächlich wegen Darkmode.
Wie kann man
diesen komischen Ring da überschreiben?
Von dem Fokus.
Bestimmt irgendwas mit Fokus.
Fokus.
Ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Outline oder so?
Outline 0?
Nee, das ist es nicht.
Fokus. Oder ist es Active?
Active? Nee.
Fokus.
Ring 0?
Nee, das ist es auch nicht.
Ich hab mal eine Ahnung, wie bei Tailwind, was das hier ist.
Außenrum, standardmäßig.
Sieht so ein bisschen mobile aus, ja.
Äh, ja.
Tailwind. Input.
Remove. Ja.
Outline. Ah, Border
ist es vielleicht einfach nur, hä?
Kann das sein?
Das ist Fokus.
Border 0?
Hä?
Was ist denn?
Wo kommt dieser scheiß Ring her?
CSS Frontend-Krempel.
Alter. Ach, Moment, ich bin beim Label.
Alter, ich bin auf dem Label.
Das ist ja ganz verkehrt.
Ich muss auf das Input-Element.
Ja, das ist es.
Was war es denn jetzt? Border oder?
Äh.
Äh. Outline?
Ja, Outline.
Outline ist es. Okay, alles gut.
Alles gut. Ähm.
Aber so ganz, so ganz
ohne Outline ist es auch doof, oder?
Lassen wir das mal,
lassen wir den mal Outline.
Hä? Äh, was ist denn
standardmäßig? Outline 1?
Okay. Ähm, wir können die Color,
die Color ändern.
Outline minus
Red. Nee.
Was war man da?
Gibt's da für, was gibt's da für
nice Colors?
Neutral.
Neutral 500.
Äh.
Nein.
Das ist nicht Neutral 500.
Oder?
Äh. Fragezeichen.
Wie geht das?
Wie zum Teufel setze ich eine Outline Farbe?
Ist das vielleicht
In Chrome nicht erlaubt oder so?
Oder?
Warte mal, wir machen das mal Red,
dass ich wirklich sehe, ob überhaupt irgendetwas macht.
Moment, wait a minute.
Warum ist da noch was
Und warum ist es
CSS
Was ist denn das schon wieder
Was ist das schon wieder
Ich setze es auf 0 und es ist weg
Ich setze es auf 2
Und es ist nicht komplett
Kek
Frontend Kram
Was ist denn das schon wieder
Ring, Color, Red
Das ist es auch nicht
Was haben wir denn sonst noch
Border
Was ist denn das
Wo kommt das her
Wo kommt dieser
Wo kommt dieser äußere
Was ist das
Und warum ist das nicht weg
Wenn Outline
Das macht mich wieder wahnsinnig
Das macht mich wahnsinnig
Dieser Frontend Kram
Was ist denn wenn ich das auf 4 stelle
Was passiert dann
Dann ändert sich gar nichts
Ich hab keinen Plan mehr
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung mehr
Wie das Frontend mäßig
Das wie das alles so
Whatever was da passiert
Irgendjemand
Wo ist der Auskennfuchs
Der Auskennfuchs hat doch immer richtig Ahnung von CSS
Wie kriege ich diesen hässlichen Rahmen weg
Es ist
Fokusring
Ich setze den Ring auf Rot
Das ist es nicht
Ich kann das sogar wegschmeißen
Ist eigentlich egal
Also ich setze den Ring auf Rot
Den Border auf Rot
Und Outline auf Rot
Aber
Ich hab immer noch
Einen hässlichen
Okay
Chat
Wie ist denn das in Firefox
In Firefox ist es auch so
Ja
Security-Galant General
Was ist das
Und warum ist es weg
Wenn ich das Outline weg mache
Wie kriege ich den
Und was ist es überhaupt
Was ist das für ein Element
Was da
Wo kommt es her
Bordertransparent
Aber das will ich ja gar nicht
Border
contar
Es ist ums verreckt
Es ist
Etwas hässliches weißes da außen drum herum
Frontend
Kram ist
Triggering wie
Nee das ist nicht das Outline
Weil das Outline ist rot
Und das hier ist weiß außen drum herum
Und in Firefox
Ist es
Nochmal anders
In Firefox ist es nochmal anders
In Firefox ist es blau
Und weiß
Da ist von Rot gar nichts zu sehen
What the f...
Outline Zero
Und witzigerweise
Wenn ich es auf Outline Zero setze
Ist es auch ganz weg
Firefox ist es
Grundsätzlich egal was ich setze
Das macht immer das gleiche
Ja aber Fokus kann ja damit
Nichts zu tun haben
Weil ich setze ja eindeutig Color für alle
Achso du meinst das
Ah du meinst das
In Fokus
Nur unter Fokus
Die Farben
Dass die Farben bei Fokus vielleicht überschrieben werden
Was ist das denn
Jetzt kann man ja nicht richtig gucken da unten
Boah regt mich das auf
Sieht man hier irgendwo
Irgendwas Weißes drin
No racism here
Not neutral
Background
Was ist das da gewesen
Ich hab es genau gesehen
Da war irgendwas
Shadow
Ist das ein Shadow
Hä
Offset Color
Offset
Was ist denn das
Fuck
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Was ich hier eigentlich mache
Warum ist es noch so viel
Applied
30 Milliarden Sachen
Mach rechts klick auf das H
Und dann
Ach hier
Warum soll ich Klassen hinzufügen
Jetzt und dann
Wie jetzt aber warum
Ich will ja wissen was das Weiße verursacht
Und ich will ja nichts hinzu
Ja aber warum
Was soll ich dann da hinzufügen
Jetzt kann ich hier unten gucken
Wie kriegt man
Okay das muss doch irgendwie gehen
Tailwind
Remove
Input
Cross Border
Ja genau
Shadow
Das ist das eigentlich in Shadow
Active Active gibt's auch
Moment
Active
Aha es sieht anders aus
Es geht jetzt
G
Das hat auf jeden Fall irgendwas bewirkt
Okay Firefox interessiert immer noch gar nicht
Firefox Das ist einfach voll kritisch
Es ist einfach vollkommen egal, was ich da eintrage.
So schlimm.
Front endstellt.
Ich werde verrückt.
Ich kann aber weitermachen heute.
Mir reicht's.
Genug.
Git status.
Git add.
Bam.
Einfach alles rein.
Git commit a-m.
Omega keckel.
Beste Message.
Status.
Alles committed.
Lock.
Bam.
Sehr schön.
Excellent.
Ohne den Reset-Knopf zu drücken.
Abgezogen.
Mir reicht's, Leute.
Mir reicht's.
Sechs Stunden oder so pro Gaststelle.
Wie lang waren wir heute am Start?
Das habe ich auch schon gefunden.
Aber das weiß ich nicht.
Woblords Twitch.
Ja, schlimm, dass da überhaupt zu viel standardmäßig gesetzt ist.
Ja, das sind wir an fünf Stunden hier und jetzt noch mal sechs, sechs Stunden.
Es reicht genug, genug für heute, Leute, genug reicht.
Nee, nee, nee, bis zum Umfallen ist nicht wörtlich zu nehmen.
Alles klar, ich muss mich jetzt echt ausruhen.
Langer Stream, schöner, so viele am Start waren.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, freue ich mich über eine Runde Follow.
Und ja, schade, dass das Stream zwischendrin abgeknackt ist.
Seitdem sind nicht mal ganz so viele da.
Aber was willst du machen?
Dicke Finger auf den Reset-Button.
Bis morgen früh.
Aufwachstream wie gehabt.
So ungefähr um neun oder so was in dem Dreh.
Ich glaube, ich gehe morgen früh nicht rennen.
Ich war heute elf Kilometer.
Das reicht.
War ein Tag ausruhen, das war dann verkehrt.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
See you.